[Musique]
le département récompense aujourd'hui
les onze lauréats du prix départemental
du mérite des hommes et des femmes
engagés des artistes des bénévoles tous
acteurs et passionnés dans leur domaine
d'activité c'est mettre en avant des
citoyens ordinaires qui font des choses
extraordinaires
ce sont surtout des citoyens qui
travaillent dans l'ombre et qu'on n'a
pas l'occasion de reconnaître le talent
est bien le parcours à ce moment-là et
reconnu lors de la remise du prix
départemental du mérite
parmi eux des agriculteurs des artisans
des sportifs des coiffeurs solidaires
toutes et tous avec des profils
différents mais chacun participe à sa
manière au développement de la société
réunionnaise pour la première fois la
pratique du moringue est récompensée au
travers d'un bénévole associatif c'est
quand même le département qui reconnaît
que la pile qui a mûri
ben ils méritent d'avoir une
reconnaissance donc pour moi c'est
important parce que c'est vraiment
reconnaissant le travail que le mouret
n'est fait à la réunion c'est pas le
fait que c'est david est en baisse et
plus poule tout le mauvais goût de la
réunion tout le responsable des fleuves
les responsables associative
les présidents et des associations tout
ça jean pierre boyer récompensé pour ses
40 ans de carrière tout comme charly
lesquelin artiste peintre militants pour
le développement de l'art sur notre
territoire et christophe dalot
agriculteurs de forêt pour moi ces
récompenses notre engagement notre
passion que nous met un travail au
travail et surtout notre teta d'esprit
parce que le travail que nous faire et
culture apiculteurs mais il demande
beaucoup d'investissement personnel
familial cette 15e édition du prix
départemental du mérite fait une
nouvelle fois émerger les talents
réunionnais des lauréats qui à cet
instant révèle tout leur potentiel
[Musique]